the White House already reeling from a
long list of problems now has a new
little headache to deal with first lady
Jill Biden causing some controversy and
forced to apologize for an apparent
attempt at pandering to Hispanic voters
Raul helped build this organization with
the understanding that the diversity of
this community as distinct as the
bogudas of the Bronx as beautiful as the
blossoms of Miami
and as unique as the breakfast tacos
here in San Antonio
is your strength the National
Association of Hispanic journalists not
happy with those comments tweeting in
part quote nahj encourages the first
lady and her communication team to take
time to better understand the
complexities of our people and
communities we are not tacos Joe Biden's
press secretary issuing this apology
quote the first lady apologizes that her
words conveyed anything but pure
admiration and love for the Latino
Community but the first lady finding
sympathy from some in the media
first lady's team probably huddling
today because when you know Joe Biden
that's not who she is but it didn't come
out correctly we all I don't know if we
all have stepped in it I know I have
stepped in it so
Dr Childress you know hear the humor we
get it we understood what you were
trying to do and just try not to do it
again I want to give her a point for
showing up because for four years we had
an Administration where nobody showed up
all right all right all right um
I think part of the thing about this
Greg is when you want to extend be
extended Grace then you know Karma you
should be giving that to other people as
well and conservatives re-read
everything that they're going to say or
tweet or in a speech that they're going
to give because they know that the
chances of them being canceled are about
a hundred and ten percent even if they
don't mean it even if it was just a
misstatement or even if they're a clumsy
attempt at a joke do you think that's
what happened part of me says turnabout
is fair play yeah right uh uh but you
know the big thing is playing to
diversity is embarrassing no matter who
does it and it's worse when you have to
apologize afterwards Trump didn't
apologize over that taco salad as funny
as that was him standing there over the
salad but I think it I think it is she
has apologized I think it is terrible
to compare people to food or even
Mexican food especially Dr Biden you
know she's got a medical degree she's
got status she's got Prestige I mean
she's got the whole enchilada and you
know if you look at her she's still
quite attractive I mean I bet in her day
she was one hot tamale I like her
husband who's Fallen apart like a
burrito you eat while driving that is
to do so there you go well I guess what
I'm saying is she shouldn't apologize
she didn't do anything wrong when
anybody ever says anything out of their
best intentions just leave them alone
but I do get it I do understand the the
the the desire to do it but the media
loves this stuff because if you don't
Pander you're a bigot and if you do
Pander you're a benign patronizing bigot
so they win either way well the
interesting thing was that it didn't
just come from the right you can imagine
somebody wanting to go it's unusual to
go after a first lady unless you're
Melania Trump exactly but the uh
it the National Association of Hispanic
journalists they're the ones who took
offense so that's where it was again
like the calls coming from inside the
house as someone who's very agile in
navigating the fine lines of ethnic
sensitivities I think it's okay what she
said it's just a matter of how she said
it you don't go to a Columbus Day event
and say you know you guys are like a
bunch of Meatballs you know you can you
can say you like Italian food right
that's the difference now as a white
Irish Catholic female from the East
Coast she could have gone out and said
you know my ancestors made a lot of
contributions to this great country but
food wasn't one of them poet Applause
and then you said in your case you guys
made so many contributions successfully
in The Culinary Department as a matter
of fact in our household my children
like taco Tuesdays better than
Thanksgiving and then you say and I had
to explain to them the pilgrims do not
eat tacos probably a lie but it doesn't
matter the problem is it thought about
political correctness has made it
impossible for whites to Pander to
ethnic groups now because they look
ridiculous when they do it because
they're like I'm the good white I'm the
Democrat white you know like I like your
music I like your food what do you want
to do the Macarena right like let's wear
like Tribal Roads and I'll kneel with
you and I keep hot sauce in my purse oh
you've got to be kidding me with that so
it and the blacks in his pants are like
can these corny white people shut up and
just tell me how they're going to reduce
gas prices so this could not come at a
worse time for Joe Biden as he's losing
Hispanic but I mean he's got the Ashley
diary out there he's got Hunters laptop
he's like Jill we didn't need this right
now who's writing your speech Jesse
Waters so it's clumsy when she does it
because it's so blatantly pandering the
Trump Taco thing was cool because it was
transactional you know Trump's like
blacks they love me I got them the money
for the the hbcs or the evangelicals I
put the judges in there and we say Merry
Christmas again or the Jews I moved the
embassy to Jerusalem you know it was
like you know I'll give you this you
give me that but when she does it it's
just cringe and that's not the way you
play it yeah um I I just on this point
judge the president's approval with
Hispanics this is according to the New
York Times poll is a 32 approved 63
disapproved it's not because of a line
about breakfast tacos it is about the
policies including energy policies gas
prices inflation obviously education Etc
that's the answer to the question and I
think you're asking and and that is that
this is this is minuscule in the scheme
of things the reason that you know he is
at a loss with Democrats and I recall
last week it was 26 percent of the week
before uh approval rating among um uh
Hispanics was because he isn't in favor
of protecting the Border he isn't in
favor for protecting the Safety and
Security of the American people as it
relates to Crime he's not fighting for
gas prices all the things that you know
the Hispanics are no different than the
rest of us they're people they want to
make sure that they've got money in the
bank or money at least to pay their
bills and they want food for their kids
they want their kids to be safe but this
pandering some of it is bigoted I must
tell you and I'm not going to criticize
her I don't think she matters in the
scheme of things right she really
doesn't and I I think it's it's
outrageous that you know every time
Melania Trump tried to show up for
anything during the Trump years they
Destroyer before she even showed up and
then they say oh she never showed up
come on she tried a million times no one
would cover remember they made fun of
her about speaking five languages yeah
yeah and they said she was illiterate or
something but but but my point is this
that you know you can't assume that
you've got any particular group and you
can't Pander to them and you can't say
you know if you if you're you're not
black if you don't vote for Joe Biden I
mean let it all go we're all Americans
Just Let It Go Joe Biden had that
comment years ago I don't remember it it
was at a 7-Eleven something about the I
think it was the Indians I mean stop it
stop it we're all American as you said
as Jesse pointed out um it was like well
that's okay that's just Joe yeah that's
just yeah but if it was somebody else
would be something worse I do want to
just play this sound bite from Paul
bagalla for Harold this is about the
fact that you've seen in the last
probably 35 days or so Joe Biden and the
administration being attacked by other
Democrats so here's Paul pagala on that
the guys had pretty pretty rotten string
of luck but this problem with young
people is especially acute and you're
right to Signal it in the election
Biden's strongest age cohort was 18 to
30 year olds yeah the young youngest
voters were his strongest at 60 I just
saw a poll recently or is it 25.
um that is in part
some of the other leaders of his party
are undermining him and undermining him
with younger voters they're they're
attacking him instead of attacking
Republicans and it's an enormous problem
okay that was a long way of saying it's
a problem that Democrats are attacking
Biden should I get everybody that had
that Marquette gift him around the table
it's under the Hat nothing
the these first of all a couple things I
agree with everything that's been said
about uh Joe Biden I think that uh
um politics has become payback on top of
payback on top of payback and even when
its lights can be smaller and smaller in
the infractions OR offenses even less
less relevant or immaterial we can't
help ourselves that was funny your
opening
um he is he is uh bagal is right the
Democrats who are who are criticizing
Biden
uh Biden's being criticized for pursuing
their way of politics in our party the
progressives and the progressives are
the ones saying he's not Progressive
enough now if I'm Joe Biden I kind of
like where he is because if the
progressives are attacking you and the
Republicans are attacking you that means
you're probably aware the majority of
the country is which is those of us that
think that we should have the right to
choose 16 to 20 weeks out to be the
thing those of us who think we ought to
have a crime commission that really goes
after uh DA's that are not doing their
jobs police Chiefs are not doing their
jobs a real focus on inflation meaning
we get back to energy and do the things
that we should be given to certainty to
these energy companies this is a moment
for Joe Biden to break out and if I were
at White House I'd be encouraging to do
the things we've talked about on this
set we talked about yesterday don't look
at this moment as a moment of weakness
view it as a moment of strength the
country's waiting for him to break out
and be the president from a disposition
standpoint that we thought we were
electing two years ago so we should stay
tuned is what you're saying I'm praying
and we Shout praying but that was good
all right up next borders are Kamala
Harris Rolling Out the red carpet from
Mexico's president but is the White
House actually doing anything to stop
the surge of migrants I want to Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now